way too little you insult the man and if
you pay too much you insult yourself
so i believe in paying a fair price for
salt is the whole reason why i say that
i used to be the person that i would um
haven't actually just talked about this
not long ago i would
austin and i have fought over tabs
before
um we we typically will always be the
first one to reach the check read for
the check
i enjoy i enjoy the game of chess in of
like
one takes a piss and the other one
really
makes their way over to the host station
and yeah i enjoy i enjoy
like the game of trying to spot the move
like the opening with when the
wind like in this case you or is gonna
go for it
it's a good time and did you do that i
did this a week ago i called ahead a
week ago
and i had was this yeah exactly i think
was it you troy in vegas who i actually
in order to pay for a meal
i think it was forgive me if i'm
forgetting
if i'm remembering this wrong i
literally had to like go and arrange
with the waiter to pay for a meal
because you're
so good at picking up the checklist to
have to pay for something i felt like we
had to
have i ever told you guys about a
birthday trick if you want to pay for
something and the waiter comes over and
is like
okay and you're fighting over who's
going to pay you like do not let them
pay it's their birthday
and then they won't let them pay it's
really good oh that's
brilliant that's genuinely great yeah i
love that
but i have it for the longest time out
of out of uh
insecurity like i would just pick up the
check and
a lot of it was because i felt i was at
the table
with people of of note or i was people
that had been
in in the industry longer than i and so
i felt insecure
even though i wouldn't admit i was like
hey guys i got this and what i didn't
realize
is that in that like if it's austin and
i or if it's like us having drinks or
whatever like ah you slick bastard
um because there's a level of
camaraderie and peer ship that goes with
that but if it's
all of us that you know if there's like
20 people and i've done that before and
i picked the check
everybody instantly feels shitty and
i was like i have to get over that so
now if ever i look at us i was like
let's split the check
that is actually a huge sign of respect
because
i i view you as a peer i don't view you
as someone
either that i'm above or below yeah a
grandstanding
subtext is one that i it never occurred
to me
that that would be a thing until i had
that experience of someone being like
wow
way to make me feel little and i was
like really
what i was like i'm trying to i was
excited to
to show you how you know much value and
meaning that you've brought me both
tonight and in general and
one little small gesture of that is to
say hey i got this
um but it it i've had it backfire
enough times where i'm like all right
maybe that's interesting i mean
i will generally like pay for my own
food like i'll do it even if i'm on a
date and that's
not a huge thing but like i usually try
to split and i know that's like
you're not supposed to as a woman but i
don't generally i'm like no it's cool
split it or i'll pay for drinks you pay
for food whatever
um but hold on is that hold on hold on
hold on is that set up before
because look it's been a while since
i've been on the dating circle uh
so i always if i asked you out
to me there was an assumption i'm asking
you out
i'm going to pay for the record every
time we've gotten drinks troy i
considered that a date so i'm literally
insulted
i wouldn't fight it but yes even if you
asked me out i would
want to split or at least pay for
something be like well you paid for this
so i'll pay for dessert um
would that be a conversation or would
that just be
i wouldn't fight like if they felt
strongly in one way or another i'm gonna
say
when would you let that be known would
you be like hey i didn't tell you this
but
when the term comes yeah i don't write a
contract before i go on a date i don't
know when i bring it up
you always start with the short reviews
i feel like
i bring it up like everything's changed
back in the day you used to have to do
the contract first i think that's phased
out over time
yeah i think it really shifted contracts
but i was going to say the only
exception of where i won't generally try
to pay my own share i've never tried to
pay for a whole table because i ain't
got [ __ ]
troy baker money apparently no no no no
neither did i i would i would put myself
in a very financially precarious
position
simply to avoid the awkwardness of the
splitting the check
damn it it had nothing to do with um
my well-being or
financial you know wealth or anything a
lot of times it was like
i better i don't know how i'm going to
pay for my rent but i just picked up
that
check for like 300 bucks my favorite
well sorry i was going to say the only
exception for when i
will not even try to pay is when i know
that we're
at dinner or at drinks and someone there
can pay for it on a company card
so if i'm there ea can pay for it i'm
not going to be like no no no let me pay
i'm going to be like no let ea
i don't that will not fight it i'm like
yes your company may pay for this meal i
appreciate that how much money are they
making off of you okay
it's when that valve card comes out and
it's like a kind of credit card you've
never seen before because there's like
five companies in the world it's like
that is
like when it's amazing second you got a
new chair
i did i did
you're on youtube once a week that's you
know that's enough that's the power i
will you know i'm just gonna
i'm gonna sit like this so the logo is
on display for your time
my favorite uh my favorite uh
total pick up the check [ __ ] up was
when i went to college one of the
people i met there one of the teachers
was a retired music editor
who had been jerry goldsmith's music
editor they did they did 90
plus films together this guy he had been
staff at fox back in the day he
he was on the scoring stage when jerry
recorded planet of the apes in 1968 like
this guy and he had worked with everyone
he worked with
john williams on et he worked with john
barry
uh you know the the original james bond
composer on the movie somewhere in time
with christopher reeve
and um don't look at the penny he he
i know yeah yeah pause real quick
there's two people on either side of me
that have no idea what i'm talking about
have you never seen somewhere in time
but i don't know it's a deficit in your
cultural education
real quickly
what it's many deficits in my cultural
education
sorry troy go ahead it should they
reboot somewhere in time
austin wintry no clearly
we should i don't think i feel like
making it all relevant to a modern
audience yeah
us modern audiences out here need some
new content yeah
dude it's it's one of the science movies
ever and it's beautifully wonderfully
tragic christopher reed christopher
plumber jane seymour
and a really really really really
magnificent timeless score
um and um so this guy his name's
kenny hall oh yeah it's uh well that's
that's the rock mountain lots lots of
people discovered that piece because of
that movie
um kind of like unchained melody with
ghosts
but um uh so kenny
hall was the music editor on just
countless countless scores
jerry goldsmith he considered to be his
big brother so here i am the biggest
jerry fanatic in the world and i get to
meet this guy
that had been in the trenches with him
day in day out
for like 40 years and also with other
just luminaries in the business and so
we
bonded immediately and it was like soon
as the semester was over it was like we
should we should be having lunch on a
regular basis so he ended up becoming a
really really close friend
until he died a couple of years ago and
the very first time we went to go to
lunch
i was in that same boat as you were
talking about troy where i was basically
within like a month out of school and
we went to go to the smokehouse which
was his favorite place he was
loved all the old hollywood places and
so
i went i got gas on my way in and i'm
pulling up and i
in a car it's all messy and dirty and
like the valet and he's pulling up in
his jacket he's so
old hollywood you know he's he's like i
came up in the 50s kid
and uh you know i ran with sinatra he's
that vibe
and um so he uh
in fact case in point he once invited me
to a dedication
at usc of their recording studio to john
williams in which william spielberg
lucas
and a bunch of other people came and the
best part was that i was standing right
there spielberg
right in front of me walks up to kenny
and just goes god i miss jerry
those first words out of his mouth which
also i thought was hilarious with john
williams right there
but um so this guy is just like he's
just this
moving human legend and and and he was
just so beloved and so i was like i am
buying this guy lunch i was so excited
to buy him lunch and the [ __ ] credit
card got rejected
because because the gas station where i
had gotten gas on the way in it tripped
it
tripped my card with fraud alert and
i didn't know that and so this was
before the time when like you would get
a text to say you know
you really do that and you say yes and
then your card is fine so my card was
just shut off
so i didn't know that i hadn't overdrawn
the balance or something and i was so
the guy comes back very
devastating oh it was i was like this
guy's never gonna
talk to me again and he was like let me
get it get it and he was so excited and
then it ended up being the first of like
a thousand
meals that we shared uh and uh but and
the funny thing is i think he
immediately forgot about it but i carry
i still carry it as like this shame
where i thought
i'm never gonna live this down he never
held it against me though
you lived it down austin and now you've
told everyone who's watching live
because hi everyone we're live
i'm alana that's is this right this time
for you troy that's austin wintery
video game composer that's mike video
game director
and that's troy baker video game why are
you inverted well like you're like top
gun right now we were inverted
because that's austin that's mike that's
you
oh i did it right no you don't have to
do it right now
from nobody else did you do it right
everything's backwards uh
we do every tenth episode live um
so welcome we did that yep yep running
thing on the show so this is um
learning about yep
we are one year old on sunday our first
episode is the 29th of november
hello monthly at the start so that's why
it's not
fifty doesn't check out at all well
that's concerned but uh happy birthday
to us thank you for everyone for tuning
in
live um it is thanksgiving or we would
have done it later in the week but you
know people have
families apparently ridiculous
um i respect it
but because of that we were gonna like
talk about a kind of lighter topic and
see
you know how quickly we end up on
toilets
[Laughter]
you can talk about it if you want you
know i won't stop you you've learned
that over 40 episodes talk about
whatever you like
but um what is the first holiday movie
that you kick it off with
like all right it's finally we can do
this
what is that thing where you're like
boom it is the holiday
season what's that that what's that
movie you throw in first i always want
to have a side channel with mike where i
was going to be like
do you do that mike because we don't do
that in australia
you don't watch christmas movies we're
not like we gotta kick off the season
we're just like yeah no it's getting hot
outside hey better go to the beach
and then we all pass out because we get
too hot the heat wave is a real problem
in victoria
one of the weirdest things about
australian christmas is obviously we
don't have thanksgiving um but i think
that uh
uh american thanksgiving is quite
similar to australian christmas where
it's all about just like eating food
with your family
from australia sometimes and sunglasses
sometimes
all right just developed my culture
that's cool change over the pacific
prison island wow
um but hey we're not we just can we just
talk about auntie donna for an hour can
we just talk can we talk about whatever
you want
but what i was going to say is we still
sell winter themed christmas decorations
so they still we still it's all still
snowy and stuff and people buy them and
it's very strange but i am planning to
have my first white christmas this year
i'm pretty excited about it i guess we
do the same thing in like
la and phoenix arizona does that stuff
where they haven't you know
sure but it's at least it is at least
the wintertime
like yeah it is quite literally like
it's just their winter means hot and
their summer means cold they just flip
australians don't all love the most
american world
that's the most american take on that i
love it
they just made them differently yeah
it's like right now the timer
i went down there it was like it's a
summer but they says it's cold i didn't
someone done full demonstrations taught
them the wrong word
wouldn't be surprised um but the
question i was going to present to the
group is you know it's it's thanksgiving
but it's also something that we want to
talk about a while ago
um just generally throwing it out there
give me
a very positive experience that you've
had
working in games something very positive
a human
or an event or even a fan that
altered you a human or a fan a human or
found
i meant to say colleague there fans not
humans as it turns out
wow i kind of that one out was gonna add
all that
um so mine is this i worked on radio
that's how i started in in podcasting
for about three years in brisbane
and we got this submission from a um
like almost 100 blind gamer uh who
had never played a video game and had
never been able to who sent us an email
basically saying
uh the way that this show specifically
talks about video games has given me an
understanding of what that experience is
the way that you guys discuss the themes
and the way things look and the way
things feel
um i guess we were we did often talk
about things on an emotional basis or a
story basis
uh has given me a better understanding
of the medium than anything else i've
ever listened to
i feel like i like just tear it up and
that changed my approach to everything i
was doing ever again
it's a thing that i had never considered
that i could be doing for someone that
we weren't intentionally doing
that uh gives you one of those oh this
is why i'm
doing what i'm doing kind of moments
that that would have been maybe like
seven years ago and just always stuck
with me
as a massive compliment but also
again sometimes you don't know that you
can be helping people in anything that
you're doing and often you can
that's that's a benefit of video games
so i could make that story a lot longer
but that's the one i'm going to kick it
off with it was uh
something that still sticks with me
today anyone else
i got a more recent one which
which is which i would i do a lot i
visit a lot of uh like unis in schools
and do talks
um and honestly usually my talk is
mainly like
don't listen to anyone who just does
talks that's usually my theme for these
talks
but i was doing one of those i can't
remember where i was
somewhere in the uk and um and the
lecturer at the uni came up to me
um and this is you know not someone
associated i don't think they were even
in the game department
and she was holding a laminated
laminated
piece of paper and it was her kid
who's like probably like
judging from like the handwriting and
the oh it was probably like seven or
eight years old
and it was their pitch for thomas was
alone too
wow and they laminated it because it was
a really important document
um and i just it was and it was amazing
like i mean
the page for
so i got like a paper and pen and wrote
the kid a letter back thanking them for
it and everything
but it was like it was just such a sweet
thing especially given that like this
kid was younger than the game
probably like that this was not this was
a kid i didn't make this game
in a world where this kid existed that's
a weird thought that like this
you know clearly like parents were into
games they'd put their kid in front
thomas was alone
i feel like visually thomas alone looks
like something that
is readily playable by children you know
colorful
it's i would like to exactly it's pretty
straightforward there's nothing in there
that's gonna
you know upset a kid or be confusing
probably just about friends and yes the
ai's
sci-fi stuff probably goes over their
heads but like yeah it's it's i think
it's fine for like a
a kid um but yeah it was and it was just
lovely that they'd done and the thing
that got me was laminating because i
remember as a kid like
that was like a big deal i don't know i
don't know if that tracks to americans
or australians
yeah laminating that's really important
it's ready to go on the voyager probe at
that point yeah
exactly right like and i just i thought
that was really touching so that was one
of those ones where like genuinely it
was like oh that's
that's amazing someone i didn't even
something that didn't exist when i made
this that meant enough to them that
they'd
heard that i was going to them their
mum's work and they're very
whenever i have any kind of you know
person under 10 be like
like at a convention or something has
happened to be like a huge fan or
sometimes it's their parent
i always have this moment of i'm never
going to swear on the internet again
uh no more sex jokes
i'm not appropriate for children at all
why are you watching my content
and then it doesn't last but every time
i'm mortified
that's like when i realized that my
mother-in-law reads my twitter and for
like a month i was very very good on
twitter
and then now i just don't
trust then i'm curious what your story
is
i have been very lucky in this
department because
especially with a game like journey um
that game really invites
uh the kind of better angels of your
nature
type experiences um it's a you know it's
a game predicated like genova first
described it to me
11 and a half almost 12 11 almost 12
years ago now
wow um he described the pitch
and it was basically like i want to make
players
feel genuine empathy and even love
without it like just
just organically where they just feel
something positive for a fellow player
and and feel like wow you really made my
life better
in some way big or small and i remember
thinking
especially back in 2009 like well i
don't know how you're gonna do that
uh but uh god i hope you succeed i mean
it was one of those that it seemed
impossible
and then of course they somehow managed
to figure that out
so because of that people have these
stories that still to this day
um blow my mind but the one of the ones
that i
thought i would tell because it gives me
props and
uh uh i it was a it was a really really
special experience
um so one of the things about where i
work
uh here in my studio is i intentionally
have no
uh posters there's no like journey
poster in here
there's no like any awards it's all in
another room because i want this room to
be about
uh making new stuff and not about
reflecting on
on old stuff and the only kind of
loophole to that
is that on my shelf uh
over i'm really bad at this right here
and a little bit over here yeah over in
that corner i've got
little keepsakes that have been given to
me along the way by various folks
and they're usually like specific to a
project
so shortly after journey came out i was
able to go down to brazil
and conduct the music in concert as part
of video games live and there were a
handful of us there some blizzard folks
russell brower and neil agree
a few others and we were signing stuff
until
like two in the morning the entire
[ __ ] audience came to the to the
signing and it's a non-union stage crew
so we were able to stay all night
and uh so this one girl comes up
in line she's really shy and she's with
her friend
and she gets out the journey art book
which
is this and i open it and
it has a signature page just like that
it's been signed by matt
nava and genova chen and i and i had
this had only just come on the market i
hadn't even seen them yet
so this was the first time i was seeing
the journey art book
and this girl who i'd had to have been a
teenager
i was like how do you have this uh
like and then when i open i see the
signature page made out to her
i'm like so i'm in sao paulo meeting
what i thought was a total stranger and
she has a signed copy of the book
it's the first one i've ever seen of
this who are you
one thing i didn't know is that because
this was a few years or a
couple years after the game had come out
they were able to publish a bunch of
fan art in the book and so uh she turns
to
this page and that's uh
her fan art that so they gave her an
advanced copy in exchange for publishing
her work and so then she pulled out of
her pocket
this with a little note that just said
austin thank you for coming to brazil
uh and this was handmade by her
and i had this moment of like holy [ __ ]
i'm in a part of the world i've never
been in this is essentially the largest
city on the planet and yet
like you fly over it for an hour before
you get to the
to the runway i mean the size of sao
paulo is hard to comprehend
wow and here somehow managed to find my
way into a room with a complete stranger
and yet had this immediate connection
and all this sort of emotional
resonance and then had and then she had
made this beautiful little thing that i
do keep on my shelf
not because it reminds me of journey or
of my music or anything but it reminds
me of just
how profoundly small this
industry can make the world and um
it was yeah there were a lot of
experiences but that's the one that i
always tend to remember because it was
such this daisy chain of like
oh cool a book wait you have a signed
one wait you're in the book
this is for me it was so overwhelming
and
uh so yeah it was it was that that i've
been very very lucky to have a lot of
really
magical moments in my career but that if
i had to pick one that was the one i
chose
to pick that's awesome i'm a fan
troy i don't know how to pick one
i didn't put too much thought into it
even though mine did stick with me you
know
you can it comes with someone you worked
with or something like that i mean there
have been
there's different things that are
magical for different reasons
there's things that have been personally
beneficial for me like i i have
some of the people that i've been able
to meet and cross paths with there have
been moments of
um even adversity and opposition that
have
taught me so much and some of the things
that i'm most grateful for about working
in this industry
were not great moments they were like
like the the whole um finding out that i
have to reshoot the sarah scene that's
not a great moment but it's a
magical moment um because it taught me
so much
yeah i feel like i feel like we haven't
talked about that
really i don't think so oh my god it's
been a year so
yeah we do tend to cycle the same story
if there for some reason are people that
have not heard this story sure i'll i'll
happily tell that story again
um i had asked neil like i had known
they laid out the entire story this is a
fun little
i guess a series of events um
let me just take it notwithstanding i i
walked in i i got
the second that i got the audition for
the last of us i
uh i was angry because i had been
pestering my agent to get me a meeting
with naughty dog
i had hung outside the room that they
were doing
um pickups for uh uncharted
2 i think at that point because i played
uncharted so bad i was just like i
i like did everything that an actress
i'm supposed to do it like sucked up to
amy hennig i did everything i just all i
want to do is just be in this game
i was such a fan of it and i'd finally
got a meeting with naughty dog and it
was for a character that i was
absolutely not right for
and i nevertheless
uh crushed the audition though they said
we do i don't think you do this but we
can do this one
um so i i go down to the audition i
never forget
it was a cold like in november it's a
cold morning i drive onto the lot and i
walk in
and i immediately freeze because i see
sat in the room is literally the picture
that is
of the character on my pages on my sides
is literally sat in somehow every person
that's around that room and i'm just
like
i am a tourist i'm a fraud i have no
what am i doing here this can you
say that you had like pretty bleached
blonde hair
at that point like i had i really like
ultra
yellow the the way that i described
myself at that point
that's silver no no no no no no no no no
no you're talking like 90s kind of end
saying
my eminem had a reflection let's just
put it that way
my shirt had too much of a graphic
for a graphic tee and i i looked i
i described it as thus i look like a
backup dancer for a k-pop band but not a
good one like a bad one
it was not good so i walk in
and i literally barely i barely get in
the door and i look around
and look at the sign-in sheet and i
haven't signed in so i realized i can
leave now and
nobody would know and so i literally
reach behind and like
grab the door handle and i'm about to
twist and open and walk out and i hear
oh troy good you're here
and it was the casting director i was
like hey
she goes actually they're ready for you
now so she walks me into the
to the stage and there on the other end
of the the far end of the room
is gordon hunt neil druckmann um
and i think i think ryan was there as
well and obviously bruce trailer was
there as well
so it's kind of like the panel of judges
were there
sorry i'm talking them simon cowell was
there for some reason
yeah absolutely terrible um
and i i i walk up the nice kind of set
my stuff down and i look and i see
this girl is pacing back and forth and i
knew that i would be reading with
someone
um but she just looks really really kind
of distraught and i walked over excuse
me and said can i give you a
can i give you a hug and she looked at
me and she's like
yes and i was like give her hug it's
like okay let's have some fun
and it was ashley and the person that
had been in right before her had just
really really gone to the mattresses and
and was trying to sell their performance
as being this tough grizzly survivor and
that's not who joel was to me
to me a person who um is a ruthless
survivor
first of all he's he became one but he's
a dad
and someone that is genuinely a person
who you don't want to tangle with knows
that about themselves and they hide
their anger they don't they don't put it
on display
and so um the the
the persona that they project is i'm a
nice guy
and what they're afraid is that you'll
find out that they're not so that's who
joel was to me so i walked in we'd go
through the whole thing
that's one little beautiful moment
another one um was when they gave us the
pitch and ashley and i sat through the
entire same pitch that they gave to sony
and we walked outside of the little
small office that stood on the side of
the stage
and at that moment over that time i
still smoked and i walked outside and i
was like let's take a break i went
outside and lit a cigarette
and ashley and i both just kind of
stared off in the distance and i said
do you realize that if this thing sucks
it's because of us shame it did too
we're gonna be the ones that [ __ ] this
up yeah terrible game kind of kind of
was
it did okay two thousand history's
forgotten
um and then the that's one of my
favorite moments and then another one
was when
um we i knew that there was the whole
sarah scene that was happening i just
asked for neil druckmann to give me some
heads up and uh he did and he said hey
just let you know that's that's coming
up
and next shoot and we did it and i
went for it and i all i knew is that you
were supposed to attach
yourself to a moment that was real and i
didn't realize that it took a lot of
skill
and i realized at that moment how
unskilled of an actor i truly was and
it was bad and i lost my [ __ ] and like
you can even see the video of it like
i've
[ __ ] wept that's not acting that's
real like i i it exploded from within me
and neil goes cut i'd like to go again
and i was
instantly terrified and i don't use that
word a lot but i was terrified because i
was like i gave everything i had i don't
have anything left i just ran the
marathon and i have nothing left and it
was like we're gonna we're gonna
you thought you're running a half you're
running a full and so we did it again
and again and again and again and again
like 10 takes and finally i'm exhausted
and he goes okay i think we got it and
so i left
i drove home i walked into my apartment
i crawled straight into my bed and i
didn't surface
until like noon the next day i was i was
just literally exhausted
and about a month later neil comes to me
and he goes
so hey there's a scene we need to
reshoot and i was like don't [ __ ] do
this to me man
and he said uh we don't have it i was
like
yeah you do and and we argued about it
for a little bit and then the next month
we actually shot it
and we went through the whole scene
again and i came into that scene
filled with with anger and and hubris to
prove to neil that he was wrong
and um he walked up to me after like the
fifth take and he goes i'm picking up on
some resistance
and i'll never forget those words and i
was like yeah you're damn right you're
picking up
some resistance because we got this in
the can and you're wasting my time and
their time everybody's time
you're going to get back in the editing
bay and find out you had it in the first
take
and he goes here's what i have i have a
man broken i was like yeah
just lost his daughter he goes here's
what i don't have
what's happening this is happening i can
fix it it's not working she's going
she's gone i'm broken
and he was right so we re-shot it
and he said he gave me one piece of of
direction he goes you know in every take
that we've done now you've never looked
at her you've never looked at sarah
you've never looked
at hannah and the second that i did
that's the take that they used
um so that means
we're almost internalizing her it was
almost like a prop
and you were 100 there was there was no
sarah there was no
joel in that there was all troy because
troy wanted to prove to everybody how
great of an actor he was
and the second that i removed troy the
actor from the scene and allowed joel to
be in it
that's that's that's all it needed so
there's moments like that where i like
man
that's the day that i learned how to be
an actor and
even even like this morning it's so
stupid i got one more story that i will
tell but
i'll i'll i'll say this one last minute
on this
um i've been reading this stupid allen
watts book
and even i was talking to laura bailey
the other day and she was talking about
she's a
a voracious reader like she reads like
four to five hundred page books
like nothing their appetites to her for
me
um i i will read i read marcus aurelius
which is 99 pages in the course of 18
months so i mean like i i take my time
with books
and i've been reading this alan watts
book for a while now and i'm about 48
pages into it
and he talks about the the um he's
setting up kind of like what buddhism is
all about and and
the the letting go and all that and we
all talk about him [ __ ] disney's sold
billions of dollars of merchandise based
on that slogan
but i never really understood what that
meant until he's
he said it's like holding your breath
and i went wow he goes breathing is good
that process is good but if you hold
your breath it becomes poison
and it'll kill you and it's pointless
so it's about breathing in this breath
and then letting it out and breathing in
the next one that's how you go through
this life as you breathe in and you
breathe
out to hold on to a breath even if it's
your favorite thing you got to let that
go and i was like
i've never thought of it that way so
these moments that i've kind of like
found these moments of breath that that
i've been able to have
i hold on to them for as long as i can
but then i have to exhale and let them
go
because i know that there's something
else that's that's soon to follow
and one of those moments was in indiana
um shout out to indiana uh
um i knew two sports teams
um so very very long story short uh
father comes up to me and i think i've
told this story before but he says
um hey i played the last of us
and i was like very cool manager you
don't understand i was like okay this is
not the normal fan interaction that i'm
used to
he says i have a daughter and i got to
that first scene that sarah scene
and i put my controller down and i
didn't touch my playstation for six
months
and i was like totally get it man some
people like no you don't understand i
was like okay i'm just gonna
stop talking and let you finish the
story and he said
that night i walked in and i held my
daughter until i fell asleep in her bed
um because just the thought of of going
through that
and that's not why i play games i play
games because
i want to have them entertain me and i
want to you know have a release and all
that stuff was like absolutely
and he said every day that i walked past
that playstation i looked at it and it
was just staring at me going
quitter quit you gotta finish this
he goes and so finally i sat down and i
just pushed through
and i played it and i got to the giraffe
scene
and he said and again i set the
controller down he goes i guess it just
dawned on me that sometimes in life you
have to push through the hard things to
find your giraffe moment
and i just started crying i was like
i gotta i gotta audition for a game and
i wanted it
so bad because it would have meant
something to me as an actor
and then i walked into that scene
because it would meant something to me
as an actor
and i never knew that a dad would have a
profound moment with his daughter
because not because of my wonderful
acting but it actually the absence of it
because i finally trusted a director and
because
hundreds of people toiled endlessly
to craft that scene and i remember neil
looking at me goes we're going to have
to invent better tech
to really capture that scene and it's
kind of going back to the conversation
that we had
last week it's not about the awards
that's why i love i never noticed that
about you austin that you don't have
the awards and the trappings of your
accolades and achievements around you
because
that is holding on to that breath you're
like dude this is where i breathe
i'll go out there and hold my breath but
in here i breathe
and i was like this is why we play
this is why it's it's never even about
the game the beauty of among us has
nothing to do with
the simple mechanics of the art style or
anything else it is about
bringing people who normally don't play
games together in a time where we
really really need it and murdering them
and murdering them
i conceded my time thank you well that
was beautiful troy
yeah are you okay man you
dude i'm [ __ ] great it's it's just
it's nice
it hits me man we're like i'm i'm really
i'm really really grateful that i get to
do what i do and it's just
i get made fun of me my whole life i've
been made fun of because i'm either
you know skinny and lanky and awkward
with no sports ability
or because i i listen to classical music
or because i play games or because i
read comic books or because i now read
[ __ ] alan once
very slowly and people like come on man
just lighten up i'm like
no i i love the fact that um
i get to see these moments of beauty in
in poignancy and just the most simple
stupid
things i'm grateful for this podcast i'm
thankful for this podcast
and there's been times when it's been
hard we've had there's four
people that are [ __ ] crushing in
their industry right now
we're busy alana got a job finally
and finally previously unemployed yeah
and you have to like fight and and the
fact that we've been able to do this and
the fact that
people are sharing with us every week
that they're like thank you for this
this has really been
uplifting and informative and
educational and entertaining and all
that stuff it's like
we're doing some cool [ __ ] that's his
life and i don't want to be very
thankful that we have an audience that
tolerates this show
that's what always gets me is like i
counted right
uh leading up to the year of this
podcast is i've worked on nine podcasts
professionally and loved all of them for
very different reasons
this one is the only one where
we can talk about anything and people
aren't like shut the [ __ ] up talk about
video games
the only one like every other show that
i've done we have one
low standard very early i know it's a
very low standard very early
we haven't been talking about stuff i'm
thankful i was going to say we're
halfway through
a mandalorian season and it hasn't even
come up we've
changed man we have to we've moved on
i'm thankful that i feel like me and
alana have brought the joy of sarcasm to
the two of you like i feel like
they're kind of the british australian
like i love you so i'm going to be mean
to you
i'm slowly but surely migrating across
to you
is that what you're mean to me i always
just it was just genuine animosity
i've had to genuinely
i've had to take like american friends
to one side and be like i'm being mean
because i love you i had that problem a
little bit
where people would be like alana's just
genuinely mean does she not like them
like you don't understand that's not
what's happening here at all
it is very confusing um but the the the
chat is currently saying very nice
things
alana specifically to all of you but
to you like just building on that troy i
i fully agree when
when we were doing it once a month and
it was like hey this
you know comic con panel was really fun
and
everybody seems to have interesting kind
of overlapping and yet distinct
uh perspectives and thoughts on life
and games specifically so we should just
shoot the [ __ ] once a month and then
once the
apocalypse settled in and and uh and a
lot of you said ah
we're here just a lot of people sitting
around what else are we gonna do
it was well but the specific way that
that that
um it was framed was you know i think uh
for a lot of folks that are kind of uh
miserably stuck indoors right now and
freaked out and don't really know like
maybe maybe they
they'd like this and my my natural
instinct is to be like
i don't think i'm helping anybody by
them listening to me talk four times as
often
yeah and so i just kind of went along
with it because i thought well you know
that i gotta get tired so um
but i i really didn't think oh it could
be helpful
it just seemed like well you know all of
us are not on planes
the way we typically had been constantly
and and
so there was there was a flexibility to
do it and uh and i've been amazed at the
the messages and the tweets and things
of people saying
exactly exactly validating your instinct
of this this has been
you know i've had some shitty times this
year and this has been a a nice
um you know thing to turn to
once a week i really i i would have
never
taken that seriously i would have just
thought it's just the four of us
basically hanging out but with the mic
on um
and uh but i like that because i feel
like that forces us to have
i love having an excuse to talk to you
three every week yeah
because i feel like i think that's just
nice because i'm someone who i struggle
to like
you know so to reach out to people and
be that guy so it's just it's just nice
to have a nice excuse to talk to
talk to you three well that's why i feel
like at the start of every episode
through the audience because there is
always a fight for us
yeah it's always a fight for us to find
the point where someone has to leave
i feel like if i didn't if we didn't
have a heart out we would literally talk
for six hours straight and the show
would just go forever
which is wonderful we all have a lot of
well that i did love especially in the
early in the early days when when we
really did have
a lot more time on our hands in the in
the immediate wake of lockdown where
it did happen all the time where we stop
recording
but we just talk for another hour and
then be like [ __ ] we should have kept
recording
yeah uh and uh and you know oh well
um or we'll we'll start the one the ones
i enjoy is when we'll start talking
we'll be talking for like 45 minutes
when we're meant to be recording this
doesn't happen anymore now alana has a
job as it's been stated
i had a job before before the time full
disclosure
were unemployed before
but like
we'd be having like 45 minute
conversations and then we'd realize
everything
we should probably record we'd have to
like or
be like oh we have to delete all of that
because we mentioned
this company yeah we did do a lot of
stop recording start recording
again and be like oh i gotta scrap all
of that or or
one of my favorites is whenever we start
a show and mike goes way oh wait troy
which i feel like we should be recording
this troy just said something
there's one of my favorites is the
episode that starts with have you ever
had a really good
shower well troy just said that
dude showers man
i i honestly believe that the reason why
showers are so powerful is because
for me is because i can't do anything
else but be in that shower
yeah i mean i think that's even if they
get that waterproof
i may have mentioned um i a
like taking a drink in the shower if i'm
like drinking a beer
i'm a huge fan of having a beer in the
shower i'd love it i don't know why i
just think it's like very nice
um a little built-in
uh a little built-in fridge uh that's
accessible from within the shower
shower in the dark makes sense to me i
get that
i've never done that it's very surreal
to be here
i think it's the sound that i like like
listening to i get that that's very
woomy
right yeah i there's a hotel in london
the me
hotel that's right there on the strand
and i
the shower the shower has like
there's like two rainfall things and
there's the two on the side and it's
just like you walk in and it's just like
you can do like the platoon just like
day day day
shower ah it's so good i will stay in
there too long
i have a lot of long showers i also like
listening to music but showering as well
like i get my thinking done so i'm like
just
me too that's what i'm saying like ideas
come to me but i i won't do that in a
bath i
i don't i don't like baths i'm not a
bathroom don't dig a dog
do you like a bath i do like a box again
i will
shower it up but being in a bath that to
me is just like
i feel antsy if i'm in a bath like you
feel like you should be doing something
you feel
hot tubs are great like there are
literally like places
i go on holiday purely based on the fact
that i could get i did that for
christmas like i said i'm planning to go
somewhere that's smelling
and uh hopefully we'll see i'm like
really banking a lot on this white
christmas that it may not snow and i
know that
but i specifically got a place that has
a hot tub and i was like i wonder how
it's outdoors
it's like house can i be in an outdoor
hot tub while it's snowing
nothing better seeing in a hot tub in
the rain is the best thing
i've never even heard oh it's up in the
rain
no if you get if you have if you talk
about having a
this is what it makes the hypocrisy is
crazy i will have a drink in the bath
or or a hot tub but it's the falling
water that's weird to me
it's great i recommend it i'll take a
coffee in the shower like not
that one's rare that one's uncommon but
i'll do it
it's incredibly dangerous to do that
episode episode 50 we'll just do it for
the shower
i am down for that [ __ ] by the way no
that's your shower
hot tub hot tub yes lots of episodes you
can make it work
yeah oh my god yeah i i ten weeks
experience um you definitely need to
experience the
the snowfall snowfall in the hot tub
that is
that is a club yeah and
well but but polar bear is cold water
so it's it's the moment the that you
realize it's back and forth isn't it
like you jump into like a s
like a sauna and then are you done
before ice
and then go into a sauna or something
like that that's just terrible
i don't know how it doesn't kill you but
it feels like it should
the cold plunge i've done the cold punch
before where you sit there and it's like
you don't move and you're just supposed
to sit there and
in the in the cold cold water and then
you go to the hot tub it's like part of
this like spa ritual thing you're
supposed to do
it's like a water course that i did once
it was awesome but there but
the moment when you realize i have to
get out of this hot tub
and you know that it's going to be so
cold and it's just like sure you end up
staying
returning i'm already anticipating that
so you know
australia has snow for anyone watching
who is not aware australia has
i call it dirt yes um
and i i used to go snowboarding like
pretty frequently so i've been to many a
ski field
and have been to the snow frequently but
it's less common that you are just
in a town that happens to have snow
you are generally there for the activity
of skiing or snowboarding um at least
you're up the mountain
right exactly so there's less of the
like oh i just happen to be in a hot tub
where it's snowing it's like
not as accessible depending on where you
live of course but that's not a thing
that i
like again even comprehended i'm already
doing the mental gymnastics of
do i get out and then run indoors like
what
it's going to be freezing is your face
cold or is the heat from
the hot tub going to make my face warm
all questions that i'm not sure what the
answers are
no that's the beauty of it like like
being in cold in a hot tub like
you're like everything above the water
is like cold warm oh it's amazing you're
feeling
yeah you just run the [ __ ] in at the end
with uh whatever
you're down now yeah i'm having these um
work out what the dressing gown
dressing ground was i feel like we i
don't i was gonna
and i wasn't sure i was like i don't
want to embarrass myself is it a rope at
that point is it a rover as a dressing
gown because i'm not going to get drunk
i'm leaving the ropes i think they're
all different things
sorry austin go ahead you are saying
something
was like oh yeah now i giggle every time
i say it when i
you're right for real when i was a kid
uh
my my dad had dug a a a kind of a
stream like a little mini uh fountain
type thing in the backyard
um and it had frozen over and and the
thing was only
a foot deep um but i was a kid and it
was it was like a sheet of ice
and they we had one of those you know
modest little
hot tub things up against the side of
the house and um
so i was out there and one day i just
thought oh you know it'd be so cool to
smash this ice with a hammer and so i
went out there
yeah and i was standing the the
brilliance of the calculation was i'll
go out and walk onto the ice and start
smashing it so as predictably
at some point the the movie moment of
like watching the
spider web form below me happen and then
it all gave way and i went falling into
this ice water
and i was stupid enough to have set up
this scenario for myself but smart
enough
to realize i might be in genuine risk of
hypothermia
because i'm basically plunging into
water below
frozen ice that's just outdoors
and so i remember just running i was
like i was convinced i had seconds
left to live you know it was like i
would have been fine but i was just like
i was convinced it was like
in indiana jones like the poison you
just drank like i was
absolutely [ __ ] and so i
remember i just ran and pulled the top
off the hot tub and just dove in
and i was also like this might also kill
me
and yeah you're right the burning the
burning of the temperature
shift was like amazing and i thought
i wonder if people know about this a lot
to see you guys about then i discovered
it's a whole thing
wait is it oh well i've done jump from a
pool to a sauna but i've told you guys
this before i don't know if i've said it
on the show
of how i if i get asthma i'm i have to
run between breathing in cold air and
breathing in steam
so i put my shower on as hard as
possible and i open my freezer
and i breathe in both of those you're
just doing the metal gear solid key card
thing
that and drinking coke uh two things
that help if if my inhaler is not
working because sometimes my aspect can
feel bad but
but uh yeah that that that you did
mention that once before and that is
baffling to me i've never i've never
heard that before that like the
the change the back and forth is what
helps it yeah
what a doctor told me and like i mean it
could be a placebo like it could be
complete nonsense but it you know doctor
told me to do it and it works so
like the damnedest thing is i also have
to be holding like a knapsack and
be on one foot and juggling at the same
time that doctor
come to think of it was in an unmarked
door in a back alley it's entirely
possible that it could be
the focus that i have on what i'm
breathing again
i don't know run back and forth between
your that's like
uh dude doctor nick you know in the
simpsons did you go to hollywood
upstairs medical college too
are you sure that's your guy um before
we wrap the show up i did want to say
you know if this is a positive episode
outside of being thankful for you guys i
did want to mention how cool it's been
for me
um you know because this is all about me
um
to see so many people praising austin
for the pathless on my own twitter
timeline people who probably don't
follow you who don't know that i know
you who have no connection to you
there's just been so much love on my
twitter for your music
uh that it's been really cool to watch
you just be like [ __ ] yeah austin like
so much of it that it's like
overwhelming
so i'm gonna make sure that i play it uh
at the end of this week
um was my plan but it's been just oh
that's very nice
so much love sent you away for shorts
you're pretty good at it austin in
fairness like music but
you're pretty good at that thing you do
yeah you've got you've got like a talent
man like you should definitely explore
that
it's it's it's it yeah as soon as i
as soon as i work through the you know
learning to
drink beer in the in the shower
i got a whole bunch of things and then
i'll take notes
because this is making a joke out of a
compliment to deflect it which is
exactly what i do
uh austin is what you've just done would
it make you feel uncomfortable if we
start talking about cannibals again
[Laughter]
no that's that's very that's very kind
it it was
i really really loved working on that
game as hard as it was
um just not not hard like
some games were hard like like abzu and
ac syndicate were both hard because they
overlapped with a really shitty period
of my life and it was really hard to
keep everything separate this one was
hard just because
it was a complex problem to solve and
the game was a was a moving target and
they you know everybody's
which are the normal good reasons for
things to be hard it was just
the standard challenges as it were that
are come with every one of these
you're only a while right it's three and
a half years
but it was so gratifying that we went to
abbey road
uh earlier this year to re i went there
with darren and we went there to do two
things
well three things we went there to
record the pattern we went there
to record the ending music from hades
and we went there to record the
songs of supergiant vinyl and it was
like to see
hades get the reaction that it's gotten
um i think it's gonna be uh funny enough
so that you know
for those that you know when you reach
the end and you hear the orchestral
music that we
that we recorded for it um i finally
last night beat it for the first [ __ ]
time
and i finally got to hear the stupid
[ __ ] we recorded
and what did you beat it with yeah out
of curiosity i use the shield
interesting for me the shield is
far and away the one that felt feels
most comfortable to me basically
abandoned all the rights
in the observatory yeah it's a good one
like a pluto reference you've got to
love it would you call it
what did you call it pluto it's called
pluto
everywhere but america where they're
like but what does the dome mean we
gotta just call it
glow in word for game
it doesn't make any sense see this is
why the americans have to call it
doesn't make any sense
[Music]
all that stuff and it's clues so it's a
game about clues so it's clued over
they'll be clever
they came to america they didn't think
americans would know the latin for
no they don't understand never clearly
not right yeah
it's pronounced because you don't get to
do that troy baker you don't get to book
that
basically i got patches on my elbows
um so on the on the note of the
apocalypse receiving a lot of love
the the two people below me have also
had massive video game launches this
year
uh and let's also not gloss over that
troy
is in the pathless uh and
he's the bad guy and and laura bailey
who he directed
is uh the hero true you also
yeah that it looks beautiful i really
need to play it i've also been meaning
to play spirit pharaoh i don't know why
my brain connected those two as having
similar vibes but
two very nice games that i was planning
on i would love to talk about spirit
fair it came up when we
had our long conversation about death
and people recommended it and i went and
played it and i have
i have a lot of thoughts about it uh and
i would i would so love to get your
takes on it yeah it was not what i was
expecting it's pretty short right
uh um i think it was
20 hours uh for me and
it's not it's not yeah i thought it was
going to be more i thought it was going
to be more
you know like you know gone homeish or
something and not at all
uh that's part of what gives me my my
thoughts that i'm curious to
discuss gotcha um but yeah i just wanted
to
to i will play it and i'll i'll hit you
up but uh also just yeah congratulate
troy obviously on uh i was texting you
the whole time that i was playing the
last of us part two
and i i did make a video that's not up
yet where i react to the game awards and
obviously it's extremely biased but i
thought that your performance is joel
that was
fantastic and there's this one line in
that game that um
uh i think it's something along the
lines of like i would like that very
much
or i would like that and the way that
you delivered that line
i just cried immediately like
immediately i was just like oh my god
uh i will i will not understand the hate
on that game to me it was a masterpiece
it is i understand the emotional
incompatibility of mike
and that perspective of feeling like
it's gonna say come at me
direct arson i know i
i genuinely loved and respected it just
wasn't totally a game for me to play
this year i will go back to him i think
that's fair
but you're taking a different time
emotionally i'll have a good time with
that i had the opposite experience where
i was glad i was also texting trump
i loved it as well like the the dying
the whole museum thing i was just oh i
loved it it's like this is beautiful
i'll still never let you do a british
accent
your british accent is of all of all the
actors who presumptuously always try
british accent in the booth with me
you're my favorite does it upset you
that i'm in a game with a british accent
troy yeah i have a british accent
afterwards what are you even doing
british
party i'm a dj i'm like hello everyone
welcome to hell
kind of unexpectedly massive from the
the possession oh look at you posing he
just went
yeah new update just dropped new
episodes
uh my incredibly talented cast i just
wanted to thank you all for um
taking us out of the box every week
having engaging conversations that i
never expect i never know what to
anticipate
and uh for sharing your wisdom with
everyone so in such an unfiltered way
um this show is one of my favorite
things to do every week and
i love the three of you a whole lot
you shouldn't agree more cool all right
well i have to get back to work now
so go to your job now not unemployed
prior to getting this job i just want to
be clear
uh thank you for watching live everyone
uh
we will be live
[Music]